so today was today was the day that the
captive aliens at area 51 have have been
waiting before and pining for the the
storm area 51 event which I'm sure you
heard about the raid on area 51
organized on Facebook was kicked off
today or was supposed to kick off today
and shockingly nobody stormed anything
they're just hanging out in the desert
having a you know drinking beer
listening to music this this mission
this righteous mission to rescue the
captive aliens has turned into a
festival how does that happen you're
organizing for raid it's a raid that
turns into a festival imagine the
disappointment imagine being an alien
prisoner at area 51 and you hear about
this raid you hear about it from the the
scuttlebutt from from the other
prisoners maybe maybe you heard about it
from rorg and snork
at the in the in the prisoner in the
prison cafeteria at area 51 and and now
you feel like you're finally gonna be
free again though the day you've been
waiting for you've been captive all this
time you start dreaming of being home on
your planet you start excitedly planning
you know your revenge invasion back on
earth to enslave and kill mankind for
what they did to you and you're just
thinking about you know if we finally
returning home to to Neptune and and
you're smiling again for the first time
in years and then the day arrives and
and and you know you you you look out
from your cell and and all you're
expecting an army of people and all you
see are a ragtag bunch of scrawny white
boys standing around in the desert
tweeting memes and laughing and you
realize it was all a joke it was all a
joke your freedom is a joke to these
people and then the area 51 scientist
comes and says it's time and they cart
you away to the hospital ward to harvest
your organs while you're still alive and
the last thing you see is your own
spleen being removed from your body
that's like a really dark turn at the
end there so I apologize for that things
got way more serious at the end and they
needed to be but the point is that the
area 51 raid
sadly a huge huge disappointment okay
well a lot to discuss today but besides
the area 51 raid that that never was
before we get to any of that a quick
word at the top from expressvpn you know
wouldn't it be nice if search engines
and social media sites were were
unbiased platforms that didn't choose a
side politically respected your privacy
all that stuff well that's a night
that's a nice fantasy that's a nice
utopian world that we can dream about
but that ain't never gonna happen all
right
that by the way that's my own phrase
that's not in the copy they would donuts
don't blame expressvpn that I just use
the phrase ain't never gonna happen
these big tech companies that push their
political agendas restrict the free
speech rights of conservatives are the
very same corporations that we are at
the same time trusting to handle our
personal data online I don't want them
using my web history my email metadata I
don't want them using my information
against me or I don't I don't want any
of that that's why I use expressvpn
every time I go online big tech
companies they can match your internet
activity to your identity or location
using your public IP address they can
find out so much about you your privacy
has just gone when I use Express VPN
these tech companies can't see my IP
address at all
my identity is masked and anonymous by a
secure VPN server plus expressvpn has
the added benefit of encrypting 100% of
your data to keep you safe from hackers
and internet bad guys does it all sound
kind of complicated maybe it does well
it's not I promise at least not on your
end as far as you're concerned just
takes a minute to set up tap one button
now expressvpn on their end there's a
lot of complicated stuff going on to
make sure that you're you're safe and
you're secure but as far as you're
concerned real simple real easy so if
you're like me and you believe your
internet your internet data belongs to
you and not the tech elites then
expressvpn is the answer protect your
online activity today find out how you
can get three months free it Express VPN
dot-com slash Walsh
that's expressvpn comm slash walls for
three months free with one year package
visit Express VPN calm slash Walsh to
learn more okay well there's something
else going on today aside from the area
51 ray
turned festival and that is a climate
strike yes there's a climate strike we
are going on strike against the climate
we are boycotting the climate we are
saying to the climate you stop it
climate you stop being so hot
I personally I'm going I am NOT going to
associate with the climate I am NOT
going to use the climate I am NOT going
to be in the climate until the
temperature drops by 20 degrees that is
my solemn oath or maybe that's not
exactly how it works I don't know it's a
it's a it's a climate strike III think
what what mainly apparent it apparently
involves is a bunch of kids skipping
school that's what the climate strike is
kids are skipping school today they're
walking out of class they're they're
letting their voice be heard I love it
when we have protests like this because
kids all across the country you know it
seems like every year there's a there's
a reason for some sort of school walkout
or whatever and and and you've got this
thing we're all kids all across the
country across the world they're
ditching class they're not going to
school and then everyone says wow the
kids must really care about this issue
these kids are really involved yeah
maybe or maybe they just hate school and
they're looking for any reason to walk
out i I can remember when I was in
school I can remember remember a couple
of occasions when we did a school
walkout I have no idea what the issue
was I don't think I knew at the time I
didn't didn't matter to me
I just knew people were walking out for
some read did make no difference to me I
was on board at least for that period of
time for that day I was marching
alongside those people for whatever
reason to whatever effect didn't matter
to me the point is the headline for me
is I get out of school and I think
that's the way it is for most kids but
on the on the sort of darker side of
things the fact is that a lot of people
kids included and adults are being
sucked into what is essentially now a
doomsday cult now just to give you an
example let me read a very disturbing
see if I can find a very disturbing
thread from a guy named Alex McKinnon
who's a writer out of Sydney
not not a grade school student as far as
I know but let me read this thread that
he put up this morning
verified account by the way on Twitter
he's got the blue checkmark so you know
he's an important guy and here's what he
this is not a joke this is what he had
to say said since the federal election
I've been overwhelmed by feelings of
dread grief and terror of what a heating
planet will mean for my life the ones I
love in our collective future
hashtag climate strike he goes on for
months getting out of bed has been
atrociously difficult and he thought of
the futures terrifying implications and
what they will mean for the later years
of my life has sent me spiraling I quit
a good jog job I took months off work I
started on medication all of which has
helped but none of which has solved the
cause of the existential horror I feel
when I look at the future in the face I
have bawled my eyes out and screamed
into pillows and felt a panic so intense
it seemed impossible it can be contained
in a small human frame I can't say that
the climate strikes have made those
feelings go away we are always signed up
for too much climate atrocity and are
too likely to cause more for a single
protest to make the situation entirely
better but to see tens of thousands of
people all grappling with the same
trauma and hurt and gut-wrenching fear
the single big biggest protest I've ever
seen in my life made my own little
battle a little bit easier for a while
we are all headed for a future
demonstrably worse than the present in
ways we cannot predict the world would
be brutal and horrific and beyond
endurance but I will help you through it
you know any way that I can I hope
you'll help me too this has to but now
now that I'm reading it all the way
through this guy can't be serious I'm
looking at his profile I I think he is
serious yeah I think he's serious and I
can't even I mean I came
laughs I can sort of laugh about it but
I but I can't fully laugh about it
because this is the I mean peep this is
this is a doomsday cult this is this is
like this that's not an exaggeration at
this point there are people now to some
of us those of us who are a little bit
more balanced we can laugh this off but
there are people I guess when you when
you've got prominent individuals like
AOC and pretty much any Democrat
liberals across the world in the country
when they're insisting and saying over
and over again the world's going you
know coming to an end it's gonna end in
12 years and and you know there's all
these coastal cities are gonna be under
water we're gonna drown it's like there
are people who hear this stuff and they
really take it seriously now think about
this the walkouts today then things like
the climate confessions on nbc.com which
we talked about yesterday gave you a
chance to it anonymously confess your
sins against the climate and then there
was the confessions to actual plants at
a liberal seminary the way the seminary
that we talked about the day before
yesterday and on and on and on it's very
clear that you know I call it a doomsday
cult well a cult is another word for a
religion cult is you know religions are
technically cults and I say that as
someone who's a member of religion
myself that's the word cult has taken on
this this pejorative meaning but in a
broader sense you know in a broader or
less pejorative way you know religions
and cults are sitting as synonymous so
you could call it a doomsday religion a
doomsday environmentalist religion and
that's where that really is what it is
and that's that's not a joke it is
literally a religion it has all of the
hallmarks now of a religion it has its
core ideological tenants it has its
apocalyptic vision it has its rules and
codes of conduct
it has tithing xand offerings and
sacrifices it has a call to repentance
it has its high priests and priestesses
AOC being one of them
it has its profits Al Gore it has its
child saviors Thune burg it in every
sense this this is a religion it's got
everything that a religion has America
has found its religion and this is it
this I think speaks to a certain truth
which is that apparently they would seem
religion actually is a basic need that
we have as human beings we can't escape
it even when we try the West the West is
by far the least religious of
civilization in the history of the world
but only at first glance and only if
you're if you're believing if you are
looking at the the polls and the surveys
and saying how many people are
unaffiliated with any religion well
there are more unaffiliated people today
than there have been at any other point
percentage-wise but if you look a little
bit closer and you don't even have to
look that close you see that the
religious instinct has just manifested
itself in a slightly different way it's
not they're not really unaffiliated
they're just affiliated now with a
different religion and one that we don't
call a religion even though it is now it
would seem that there is a fundamental
need here and if you're an atheist you
can claim that the fundamental need for
religion the instinct to whatever you
want to call it you could say that it's
evolutionary its cycle it's
psychological whatever it not proof of a
god that could be your claim if you're a
theist you say that the fundamental need
speaks to an innate sense of an innate
knowledge of in an eight longing for the
divine I'm not gonna get into that
debate though you know where I stand on
it but that's that's not really my point
here my point is simply that the need is
clearly there for religion and
environmentalism fills that need for a
lot of people and it's not a coincidence
that as we go on it begins to more and
more resemble religion and it takes on
more
or of the characteristics of religion
this repentance stuff it would that we
see two of these things in the same week
we're now and now this confessional
aspect of it is uh
to me that was kind of like the last
piece that we needed to really call it a
religion and now we've got it and okay
so it's it's a religion you could just
classify it
you've got Christianity Judaism Islam
you know Hinduism environmentalism right
in the list of of religions all right um
I've been meaning to mention this for a
few days a restaurant in Baltimore is
being accused of racism and this is
going to shock you the reasons are
frivolous and stupid if you can believe
it a frivolous claim of racism that
doesn't sound like the culture I know it
doesn't sound like our culture so
reading out from the deli wire says a
soon to be opened restaurant in
Baltimore hat is being called racist
because it posted a sign with one
specific message the restaurant has a
dress code the Choptank which alerted
prospective customers that will be
opening soon on its Web site posted a
dress code listing some items that would
be unacceptable to wear on its premises
including excessively baggy clothing
offensive vulgar or inappropriate attire
athletic attire jerseys brimless
headgear backwards or sideways hats work
and Construction boots sunglasses after
dark
on Twitter one Twitter user described
themselves as a photojournalist tweeted
dress coded sign at the new Choptank
restaurant in Fell's followed by another
tweet and then from there the
controversy starts one Twitter user said
this is racist as hell I will never
enter your restaurant and will actively
warn others away from it have a great
day someone else said y'all could have
saved yourself some time at the Choptank
and just posed a no black people sign a
writer from Elle magazine tweeted the
restaurant had a blatantly
discriminatory dress code the Washington
Post is writing about it on and on
people are calling a racist this this is
one of those cases where the people
calling it racist and this happens a lot
where the people who call something
racist have revealed themselves to be
racist because if you read that list and
you think oh that's gonna disqualify all
black people how is that not racist art
are you just is that not engaging in in
in insulting stereotypes no this is a
dress code that is put forward for
everybody and there's a logical reason
for a lot of it like for instance one of
the reasons why establishments don't
like really baggy clothing especially in
the city is because you can hide stuff
in it like a gun for instance oh they
don't want vulgar attire
where well that's that most most places
don't want that because that offends
other customers and you don't want to
offend paying customers
you don't wear athletic attire well
again that's that's just if you're
trying to be a slightly nicer kind of
restaurant maybe one step up from Burger
King or subway then you don't want
people walking in and in basketball
shorts don't wear sunglasses after dark
again this is just this and that's a
that's another thing there are a lot of
places if you go into a bank it's gonna
say don't wear sunglasses and hats in
the bank is it discriminatory
no they're just because you might be
trying to rob the place so to look at
that list and say that it's
discriminates against that to me seems
extremely bigoted and racist I think
that a dress code like that seems to me
to be completely reasonable no matter
what your race happens to be anyone of
any race is perfectly capable of
complying with that dress code and and
it should really be as simple as that
all right not to go to rapid-fire here
but I've also been I've also been wanted
to talk about something else and I can't
let the
and without without bringing this up and
I'm sorry that I have to talk about well
I don't really have to talk about it
but I will anyway the New York Times a
few days ago ran a story and okay well
here's the headline of the story all
right
the headline is but it's not a story
it's a it's a op-ed women poop at work
get over it
that's that's real that's that's the
headline in fact here's that here's the
screenshot of that of the headline there
so just so you can see this was
published in the New York Times and it's
an article all about well you could tell
what it's about it's kind of self
explanatory and this is this is
something I talk about a lot
I'm not women pooping but but but but
rather feminists finding the weirdest
ways to be persecuted just the weirdest
feminists are so desperate to be victims
and so desperate to be persecuted that
they they go searching for it and they
find it in the weirdest places and they
find the weirdest claims about
discrimination that they face like who
ever told women that they can't go
number two at work is that even a thing
in my 33 years of life I've never heard
anyone say that or I it just is I don't
think that's a thing or are there jobs
where they say where like you walk into
the bathroom and there's a there is a
gendered code telling you what you're
allowed to do in the bathroom like men
can go number one and two women can only
go number one is is that a thing or
their place are there jobs that have
rules like that if so I will say I'm
totally against it I I I have no pride I
will I will march with the feminists in
that case and say no men and women
should be allowed to you know use the
toilet at work but I don't think that's
a thing the real story here is the
picture accompanying this article this
to me is is utterly mysterious but I
want to show you this picture this is
the
picture that went along with the
headline and as you can see there okay
what it just makes me it really makes me
wonder the woman who wrote this article
she obviously has had some very specific
experiences at her job which I don't
know if she works in the New York Times
or if this was or what but there are
weird things happening in her bathroom
at her work that I don't think happened
at other places oh look okay
you've got a woman with her shoes off in
the bathroom and her bare feet on the
floor and then you've got that appears
to be I don't you know I I don't want to
be transphobic but that appears to be a
man in that one I mean is it someone
with pants they're facing in the other
direction
here's to be a man and then you've got
two women in the stall next to it what
in the world is happening in this
bathroom
what is this even supposed to be so the
real headline of the story is very weird
stuff happening in New York Times
bathroom if you go to New York Times do
not use their bathroom under any
certaintly for a woman you're not
allowed to or I guess you can but maybe
they have to do to us is that okay maybe
that's the issue maybe at the New York
Times to save space they make women
share stalls and that's why they're not
allowed to anyway I don't want to get
too graphic with it but this is a just
completely bizarre and strange all right
we'll go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Kevin says hey Matt I read
your article on The Daily wire about
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau wearing
blackface and how we should apply the
left standards to them I know that this
is something that a lot of conservatives
struggle with their insistence that lost
my place that conservatives should not
jump into the the mire of leftist PR
tactics while I agree that the Left
should be called out for their blatant
and unwavering hypocrisy for what they
did to megyn kelly in treating Trudeau
and Ralph Northam with kid gloves I
believe that we should not attack sure
no and look at the tote the totality of
the circumstances well I don't agree
with my nature those policies the man
does not deserve to be destroyed for
something for doing something
ignorant and stupid this is the best
and we should not engage in leftist
attack strategies just wanted to give my
thoughts well this is what I've been
talking about over the last few days and
and I agree it is I've been wrestling
with this as well what do we do we we
accuse the left of having a double
standard we don't want to ourselves have
a double standard so if we say in
principle that we don't think that
people should be destroyed or fired or
canceled over dumb things they said or
did 20 years ago or 30 years ago or
whatever then how can we all of a sudden
abandon that argument when it's a
leftist who's got themselves into
trouble and that's where I tried to
thread the needle yesterday and and the
way that I kind of look at this is yeah
we don't want to be disingenuous so we
don't want to come to the Trudeau
blackface thing I think any any rational
especially any conservative we see that
and we know that objectively speaking
not a big deal it's not racist you want
to call it insensitive go ahead you want
to call it stupid sure it's not racist
okay his intention clearly was not to be
racist so we know that and so we
shouldn't be disingenuous and go around
pretending that we really think it's
racist unless we're doing it ironically
as a joke in which case go ahead but I
do think as I said yesterday we this
from our with this kind of thing our
point should be okay this is not a
racism scandal this is a hypocrisy
scandal so it's the same thing with the
New York Times editor who who was who
herself has participated in canceled
culture tried to do retweeting thing's
calling for Shane Gillis to be far from
innocent Nell then it turns out that she
has all these offensive tweets where she
has said offensive things about gay
people and people of other races and so
on well our response to that is not that
oh this person is a horrible bigot and
and and and all of that but it's just
this is hypocrisy this person is a
hypocrite
clear
Justin Trudeau is a hypocrite and so I
think there's nothing wrong with us
saying okay you forget about the
standards we hold you to you should hold
yourself to the same standard that you
hold other people to I think that that's
a perfectly fine perfectly consistent
message that is an intellectually honest
way of approaching this from our
perspective perspective where we are
saying to these people like Justin
Trudeau hold yourself to the standard
that you hold other people to just like
the comparison I drew yesterday I think
it's an apt comparison think about what
the left says to socially conservative
Christian Republican politicians who end
up in scandals where they're having
affairs Larry Craig in the bathroom
soliciting gay sex what do the left say
in that case there are messages hey you
know we don't think this kind of stuffs
a huge deal but you're the ones that
you're the one putting yourself forward
as this conservative Christian family
values Christian values so on and so
forth
hold yourself to the same standard that
you live up to your own standards you're
the ones who say that this is a horrible
evil thing it's terrible the collapse of
morality and everything else so hold
yourself that's it by your own standards
you should resign in disgrace because
that's what you would expect other
people to do who have done the same
things and in that case I agree with the
left I think that's correct well I think
we can take that and throw that back at
them here and say well here you go
this is your standard we aren't the ones
as conservatives okay we're not the ones
going around saying that everything is
racist we aren't the one saying that if
you know somebody said it makes a joke
five years ago we should destroy them
now that's that's not our thing we
didn't we didn't invent that that's not
our opinion but it is your thing that is
your philosophy so apply it to yourself
be consistent all right let's see this
is for
sam says hi Matt longtime listener
big-time fan I'm well aware of your
opinions on issues such as people facing
facetiming in public people sitting next
to you on planes one other seats are
open etc I would like to know your
thoughts and when you were using a
urinal in a public restroom and someone
comes in and decides to urinate right
next to you when other your nerves your
own urinals are available I believe this
is sociopathic behavior do you agree
I guess we're talking a lot about
bathrooms today I didn't plan it that
way but that's the way it's turned out
and yeah Sam I sociopathic yes
psychopathic I would advocate I think
the death penalty in those cases you
could make an argument for it that's all
I'll say I think I think as a society as
a country we need have a national
conversation about what do we do about
the sorts of people you've got a line of
urinals your there's all of them are
free except for the one you're using
someone comes in uses the one right next
to you could make an argument for not
only criminalizing that behavior but
making it you know considering at least
capital punishment in those cases I
don't know but we could talk more about
that but I think there's certainly a
rational argument to be made there
thanks for the email finally this is
from Addison says dear he who must not
be shaved as a fellow lay theologian I
commend you for continuing the tradition
of maintaining your beard anybody who
attempts such deep discussions without
facial hair should automatically be
marked as a heretic without exception
totally totally agree
speaking of theology I've stumbled upon
a rather unique discussion of my studies
many years ago somebody introduced me to
a documentary titled divided the
filmmaker Philip Leclerc like lek lurk
le c le r ce asks a very important
question why are the youth in our
churches falling away in such terrible
droves if I'm not mistaken I believe the
current statistics range between the
high 80s and low 90s that is a
staggering number one of great concern
obviously but his diagnosis of the
illness is even more bizarre rather than
blaming it on lack of discipleship
sugarcoating preaching or the absence of
apologetics he more or less points the
finger towards the institution of youth
ministry his argument relies on two
premises premise one there is no such
thing as a youth pastor in the Bible
premise
the Bible teaches family integration not
separation in the context of worship
conclusion therefore youth ministry is
outside the will of God now I don't want
a straw man his argument so I'll grant
that maybe he doesn't hold to the first
premise as strongly as the second
premise regardless he and several other
others strongly support the second
premise and cite various scriptures to
proof their claim the idea is that
parents have to be involved in the
discipleship process or else the
children were most likely fall away
during high school and beyond the more
committed the parents are the more
committed the children will be therefore
youth ministry is not part of God's plan
because of wedges children it wedges
because of wedges children from their
parents and further divides between them
children looked to youth pastors as
father's and in most cases just play
games and flirt in rare instances the
youth pastor actually disciples but even
this is dangerous because it fails to
recognize the family as a God ordained
institution and Rob's parents of the
love and devotion of their children
church should be the place where they
grow together not separate I obviously
disagree I'm reading this like I'm Ben
Shapiro over here I speed reading I
obviously disagree with the first
premise because many things are not
specifically mentioned the Bible that
are still permissible also it airs on
the inside of legalism when we get
wrapped up in condemning things that the
word is not specifically condemned as
for the second premise I'm not entirely
sure to be honest in one sense I do
agree that it would be ideal to
encourage parents to have their children
sit sit with them in church services on
the other hand we should be so we should
should we be so quick to dismiss a
ministry that may indeed harvest young
believers as strong committed disciples
would this categorize under unnecessary
dividing the body over trivial issues or
is this a rather a discussion that needs
to take place and receive our
consideration all right Addison I think
you you've raised a lot of interesting
points which is why I wanted to read
that I'm sorry for reading it so quickly
hopefully people could understand what
you had to say I I agree with with much
of what you say and of course the
question of why are so many people
leaving the church why are so many young
people leaving that is one of the most
important questions we can be asking now
as a church as a as a a body of
believers in America now you say 80 or
90 percent leave I don't know I don't
know if it's that high that seems a
little too high if we're looking at 80
or 90 percent of kids eventually leaving
the faith then that means the church in
America
extinct in 50 years if not sooner that's
just that is not an all sustainable that
is apocalyptic kind of numbers I tend to
think I'd have to see where you got
these numbers I tend to think that those
numbers are not exactly you know maybe
inflated a little bit but but anyway the
point is it the numbers are too high as
for youth ministry first of all not all
youth ministry has to remove kids from
worshiping with the parents and it's not
how it works in the Catholic Church for
example most Catholic churches anyway
you know you got the service you've the
mass as we call it and in families are
together and then you have the youth
ministry which is a separate thing and
kids will go for youth group meetings
and and and youth services and they'll
do that stuff it's a separate thing that
they'll do oftentimes on different days
of the week they go to youth retreats
and everything else I agree that
families should be together in worship
ideally doesn't always work out that way
of course but can't always work out that
way but I think ideally that's the
that's what should be encouraged having
the families together so I'm an
agreement there with that argument I
also agree that youth ministers or youth
ministries in general can sometimes be
frankly just BS a waste of time that can
be very cliquey very I suppose I would
the word is worldly that we would use
not all the time certainly but they can
tend that way
and so that's something that you gotta
look out for I remember when I was in
high school and a few you know my
parents were encouraging me to get
involved in youth activities at the
church and I made a few attempts and I
just was I was turned off by it because
it just seemed like is like I said very
cliquey which I think which from talking
to other people that's a big problem in
youth in youth groups and youth
ministries at churches and in churches
in general you know frankly and but on
top of that it just to me it seemed like
what's I don't know everyone's just kind
of hanging out which is like fine I
guess if you want to hang out I who
doesn't like hanging out but I there
should be probably more going on
than that but actually as I was thinking
about your email what I would like to do
I want to put all that aside for a
minute and address this question of why
so many kids so many young adults as
they grow up end up leaving because it's
a very high number as we said it's a big
problem it's something that we need to
think seriously about and I don't think
there's one answer but I would like to
suggest an answer one of the answers I
think one of the important answers I
would like to suggest I think one of the
reasons why a lot of people end up
leaving the church Christianity
faith is YouTube and the internet more
generally this is we would make a
mistake to to to discount this factor
now I don't mean that YouTube and the
Internet are are the devil
though I mean who knows you could maybe
argue that but what what what I really
mean is that at a certain point people
Christians a lot of them start to ask
difficult questions about their faith
about their belief system about their
their history as a religion about their
theology they're their books you know
people start to wonder they start to
question they start to notice things as
they grow older that they didn't notice
before when they were kids they start to
do their own research okay and and they
think you know oh Jesus well the Genesis
creation account is pretty strange when
you when you look at it especially
considering what we know about about
science and why are there two of
creation accounts that seem to conflict
what's going on what is going on with
this Noah's Ark story what really is
happening here and why is it so similar
to other stories like the epic of
gilgamesh and that flood so anyway
what's going on with the exodus so why
isn't there they when I look it up
online I see that there's there's hardly
any archaeological evidence to support
it
now why does God send bears to maul 42
children and
wait did God really just endorse slavery
explicitly in the Bible what's with all
the wholesale slaughter in the Bible and
you know what about the New Testament
what about the infancy narratives and
the fact that if there appear to be only
two you know the two infancy narratives
that seemed to really contradict each
other and be two completely different
stories and why don't the other two
Gospels even mention the the virgin
birth and what's going on with the
resurrection accounts how many angels
were at the tomb and what happened
afterwards and who went to the tomb and
who left where'd they go and what
exactly is happening here and and wait
when were these Gospels written and by
who and how do we know that and and and
you know ways like what is with this the
whole idea of atonement what's up with
that you know why did God need Jesus did
I to forgive us why couldn't he just
forgive us without that and why does God
allow all these horrible things to
happen disease isn't everything and and
what about evolution and why didn't God
ever mention that and on and on and on
or not okay the point is I think people
a lot of young people at a certain point
they start to ask these questions okay
it's a lot of people these are and these
are good questions these are these are
good tough real questions but then
here's the issue where do they go for
answers they go to youtube they go to
the Internet they go to Google okay and
why do they go there for answers it's
not their fault
that's a it's a perfectly reasonable
thing to do you've got all these
questions so you go to the internet you
look it up they're forced to do that in
many cases because our churches for the
most part are not addressing these
problems are not even acknowledging them
are ignoring them are not even trying to
provide answers are not addressing these
things head-on and what happens is that
people start asking the questions that
the churches have ignored and that their
parents have never addressed and they go
online they go to YouTube they find
things out they learn things they notice
things they start to feel lied to they
start to say why didn't anyone ever tell
me about this why did why what wait a
second and they start to feel like
things were hidden from them and their
faith completely
apart at that point it's like a house of
cards it just tumbles down it's just
it's just it's just it just all falls
apart and you lose them and I really
believe this is what's happening in so
many cases in fact I know that this is
what's happening because I get emails
from people all the time all the time
describing exactly this kind of process
you have no idea how many emails I get
describing not only exactly this story
this this you know this narrative of
their own life and you know this is how
it works them but but but asking me a
lot of these questions that I just
rattled off you know and there are
hundreds of others that people people
could ask related to religion they asked
me these questions now why is that is
that because I'm some sort of I'm so
sort of genius theologian or scientist
no I'm not a genius I'm not a theologian
I'm not a scientist I'm just a guy
babbling on the internet but that is a
reflect that they have to come to me of
all people to answer these questions is
a reflection of the fact that the people
in their lives who should be answering
them or at least addressing them are not
they find me on YouTube and they say let
me talk to this guy because they're
pastors not talking about their priests
isn't talking about their parents aren't
talking about their religious education
people you know they went to Sunday
school they went to a Christian school
Catholic school these things were never
talked about and what I hear in emails a
lot is is sometimes they'll go and
they'll try to talk to the pastor
they'll try to talk to some people in
their lives and ask them these questions
and what they get are platitudes they
get evasion
they sometimes they'll they'll get the
distinct impression the person they're
talking to has no idea hasn't even
thought about this stuff before I think
it's so important for us to realize this
because you know I think we need to stop
looking at the problem as one of purely
about you know shallow self-centered
Millennials who want to leave
Christianity so they can go and run off
and sin or whatever I think that you
know maybe that's the case sometimes but
I think we make a big mistake it now
makes us feel better to look at it that
way we want to see it that way okay we
want to say that all these people
leaving I mean they're just not as pious
as I am you know there's not as strong
and in their faith they're not as bloody
they're not as whole
as I and that's why they leave those
wimps those weaklings when in reality no
it could be in some ways the opposite
that they had the courage to start
asking questions but unfortunately
nobody was there to answer those
questions and unfortunately they didn't
really know where to look for the
answers so I think
we need to start I think Christians need
to be trained educated really educated
in it you know and and now and we would
know this - it's the other thing when
we're trying to answer the question of
why do people leave the church you know
one thing we could do is ask the people
who've left let them tell us okay now if
you ask people they might tell you they
left because they're disenchanted with
the church they're dead personal
problems with somebody in the church
they you know so on and so forth you
know you will hear stories like that yes
but just as likely they'll tell you
something about some of those questions
that I mentioned before some of those
problems and they'll tell you that the
best answers they could find for those
questions or secular ones from secular
sources you know and and so what we want
to do is we want to make ourselves feel
better we want say oh no no that's not
really why you left no that couldn't be
it that's not it I'll tell you I'll tell
you why you left because I know I know I
know better what's in your mind than you
do do we even need the help pretentious
and arrogant and stupid that sounds no
no it wasn't really that no that's cuz
you wanted to sin that's what it was
tell you no no you don't know no it
wasn't let me tell you no no let me tell
you why you left no I think we need to
listen III I think maybe we could listen
let's listen to what they're saying for
a change what ultimately needs to happen
is the church needs to help to form
mature Christians with a mature
understanding of their own religion and
their Bible this is a big part of the
problem is that a lot of adult
Christians in this country have a very
immature childish understanding of their
religion and of the Bible
and the problem with an immature and
childish understanding is that it won't
hold up
scrutiny and also the other problem is
that you if you're a parent if you're a
leader in the church because you have
yourself a childish immature
understanding of your own faith you are
not going to be able to answer the
mature intelligent questions from people
who are apparently more mature than you
I mean I can't say how angry I get when
I hear people that say you know I had
these questions I talked to my parents I
talked to my pastor and it was like they
never thought he's how could you be an
adult Christian you never even thought
about these things what the hell is
wrong with you use your brain I think
there are a lot of there are a lot of
Christians who still think of the Bible
like a self-help book I run into this
all the time you know Christians you
think of the Bible as a book of
inspirational sayings you know but it's
not that there's inspirational stuff in
there but the Bible is a library of a
whole bunch of different books and
genres and forms and styles written over
of course a thousand of a thousand years
at least hundreds of years maybe a
thousand years by dozens of different
authors who were all trying to do
different things and none of them had
any idea they were what their writings
were going to one day be compiled in a
book the book that we now call the Bible
and we have to understand that we have
to understand what it is and what its
many different functions are and in were
and were supposed to be or else we're
setting ourselves up for a crisis down
the line when the Bible doesn't quite
live up to or rather I should say
conform with our expectations recently I
saw somebody on Facebook that post a
picture of their Bible with a cup of
coffee and in the caption she claimed
that every morning she opens the Bible
at random and and she finds her morning
inspiration wherever it lands you know
she lets the spirit guide her opens the
Bible and and and wherever it lands she
finds inspiration and I read that and I
thought really really is that really
what you do because first of all if you
really read the Bible every morning you
aren't you're not posting pictures of it
and posting it on Facebook okay but
second of all because if you really open
the Bible at random if you open it at
random and you stack the deck in your
favor because you kind of know where's
the salt
are or you could kind of flip it maybe
and try to land on Matthew chapter five
get to the Sermon on the Mount so you
flip all the way back to the epistles
you try to get somewhere at Romans or
Corinthians or something you know then
then yeah you'll find a lot of
inspiration that's very relevant to your
life today but if you're really opening
at random there's a good chance you're
gonna land on a six page long genealogy
or a long dense discourse on Jewish
ceremonial law or dietary restrictions
or a description of some violent siege
that took place or a conquest that
happened or a prophets lengthy
denunciation of this or that group of
people or dozens of other things that
that would be very difficult to
at-a-glance over your coffee in the
morning find inspiration from why is
that because the entire Bible wasn't
written to inspire 21st century
Americans while they eat breakfast some
of the Bible some of the Bible was
written to inspire yes some of it is
inspirational writing some of it was
written written with other purposes in
mind and to do other kinds of things and
so that I just I pointed out as an
example of the the immature silly
frankly ridiculous you know impression
that a lot of we Christians have about
our own religion and our own holy book
that we claim to read every time I read
the Bible every day
do you do you really read it do you
really study it do you really know
what's in it because if you do you know
it's just anyway so I think I think
that's that's that's a big part of the
answer is for us to so let's begin with
ourselves as Christians you know in
our own understanding of our faith in
our religion coming to a more a deeper
and more mature understanding of it
reading you know not just the biblical
text itself but the history around it so
we can understand the context of it it's
a big part of it there's a lot of stuff
in the Bible and some of some of those
questions I rattled off art it's easier
to answer those questions when you
understand the context surrounding wind
of these these of these texts were
written and why you know if you don't
know any of that and you just pick it up
and read it there's a good chance you're
gonna walk away confused
disturbed even so that's my thing and
it's got to start in the churches I mean
pastors got to get up there and start
giving substantive sermons addressing
real questions and issues people have
related to the text related to their
religion related to just real stuff we
don't need an inspirational self-help
sermon every single time people have
real questions answer those questions at
least acknowledge the questions I feel
very strongly about this as you can tell
but I guess I should wrap it up it's
been about 30 minutes of me babbling
about this I could go on for another
five hours on this subject as you could
tell but we'll leave it there for now
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great weekend Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stephens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
[Music]